the way I look at built to become that
it means not that there is some founder
or founders who have a vision at the
outset that is going to be invariably
pursued by whoever comes after them but
that they do actually have some
principles that explain why they were
successful to begin with and build an
institution that already lasted at least
for their time as not just founders but
also leaders of that company and that's
built to become means that the leaders
who follow the founders understand what
those key strategic principles are and
try to continue to pursue the activities
of the company in the future living by
those principles these principles they
have to be pursued by and reflected in
what I call the strategic leadership of
the company so that means that it's not
just leadership that matters it does of
course but it is strategic leadership
that matters and by strategic leadership
I simply mean that all the leaders in
the organization who commit the
resources of the company the people the
technologies the financial resources the
reputation of the firm that they all
have a strategic mentality which means
when they take actions they let those
actions be informed by a thinking
process that asks are these actions
going to continue to secure the success
of the company in its competitive and
collaborative endeavors
I have developed a framework for
identifying four different situations of
what you could call strategic leadership
regime and while no company of course is
exactly going to fit in each of those
four types an interesting question at
any moment in time is to ask in which
direction are we moving are we moving in
a direction in which there is both
strong top-down and bottom-up leadership
which by the way is only possible if
thought management wants it of course or
are we for instance that are we moving
in a direction where stop lead down
leadership is becoming weak and but
bottom-up leadership is still quite
strong which might and which might lead
to it at the danger that the company
begins to drift as opposed to having a
clear direction it could also be the
moving in the direction of what I call
very strong top-down and weak bottom-up
leadership it's kind of like a lockstep
approach everybody goes in the same
direction that'll be the right direction
or you can sometimes even find a
situation where both the top down and
the Bob and the bottom-up leadership are
are actually weak and in that case the
company's leadership regime I
characterize it by you know what
physicists would call Brownian motion
and it's you just follow some particles
that just follow some random ad so
that's one key component the the
strategic leadership regime the second
part of the of the framework has to do
with the interplays between culture and
strategy so at the time of founding of
successful companies usually there is a
good fit between the strategy and the
culture the strategy is compelling to
the members of the organization and the
culture that we have is supportive of
that strategy as a company that wants to
continue to be built to become it will
have to manage the inter place between
the changing corporate strategy
and the culture that it fans when both
are aligned you have a situation of what
I call commitment and all the members of
the organization are committed to trying
to pursue the strategy that the firm has
in order to continue to be successful
and continue to live if the culture is
let's say still very supportive but the
strategy has become not so compelling or
unclear then we find ourselves in a
situation of what I call contention
which means now multiple multiple senior
leaders will try to drive the company in
different directions and they still
think that what they want to do is
consistent with the culture but it leads
to a situation where there is no clear
direction in the company so let's
contention is really competition among
the senior leaders and driving the
company forward so that's the second
part they implicate the interplay
between strategy and culture in a
dynamic league moving environment the
third aspect of the strategic leadership
capability is the the tension between
what we could call fit which is how well
are you able to exploit the existing
opportunities that you already have in
the environment with which you are
familiar that's fit and the other aspect
is evolved ability which has to do with
how much are we able to get into new
environmental segments if the
environment within which we have been
successful and with which we are
familiar is beginning to get saturated
or in fact may even decline so over time
a bill to become company will have a top
management that can balance the resource
allocation to fit initiatives and
evolvability initiative
that's the third element and the fourth
element is the link this is the link if
you want or the interactions rather
between the top management in particular
the CEO and the Board of Directors the
CEO can have a compelling strategy and
if the Board of Directors is is
functional then you will have a
constructive relationship between what
the CEO wants to do and the top
management and then where the board of
directors who represents in a public
company the you know as fiduciary
responsibilities to the shareholders
that where does two are aligned and
there will be a constructive
relationship between the between the top
management and the board of directors
whereas not always the case sometimes
the the board can become become actually
dysfunctional and then the CEO will even
if he or she has a compelling strategy
will find itself in a disruptive type of
situation with the board of directors
there will waste time trying to deal
with the dysfunctional board
if you think about the situation that
the multi business firm faces you can
think about it at least in two
dimensions again one is the evolution of
the complementarity of the businesses
maybe at some point there is great
complementarity between the businesses
and over time that complementarity may
diminish the other aspect of it is the
complexity within each business which
can evolve from let's say mild
complexity to very high complexity and
if you have a situation where the
complementarity is decreasing on the one
hand between the businesses and the
complexity of each business is
increasing then you can begin to make a
reasonable case that in fact that
company should perhaps split off some of
its businesses to put it in a position
where each business has a better chance
to again continue to exist further for
the long term because now it's strategic
leadership for each of those different
businesses will be able to do a better
job than when the strategic leadership
of the combined business is is stretched
beyond its capacity to be actually
effective